[Música]
enfim conversar com vocês nesse tempo
teddy é que nós temos sobre um aspecto
que diz respeito a todos nós
o imenso tsunami imensa mudança de época
pela qual nós estamos vivendo que toca a
todos nós independente da nossa cidade o
nosso origem nossa raça nossa economia
todos nós estamos sabendo que tudo
aquilo que um dia já foi verdade
na mais e nós estamos com a vida virar
de cabeça para baixo
em algum momento procurou chamar isso
nós estamos fechando o homem desde o
solado sem bússola
por causa disso eu imaginei um termo
chamado ferra dois pra chamar esse
planeta
uma das expressões desse termo é o
programa da tv cultura que o que eu
criei que alguns esperam que muitos
conheçam que já fez uma temporada e
agora abrirá proximamente na segunda
temporada
pra quê para abordar esses momentos de
mudança que mudança mudança do
nascimento até a morte
então eu fiquei imaginando como é que a
gente poderia representar isso de uma
maneira sensível a todos nós
por falar em academia acadêmico
a gente fala e modernidade pós
modernidade mas não é tão claro para nós
talvez a gente disser nós vivemos num
planeta agora nós temos um outro e se no
planeta que a gente vive em idêntico ao
anterior e os animais ou seja nós somos
muito parecidos com que nós éramos há 30
40 anos atrás
mas as semelhanças são da fotografia se
você ligar uma câmera começar a filmar
nossos amigos nossos comportamentos
serão totalmente diferentes
nós estamos num novo planeta não estamos
usando conta tamos com novos sintomas
novas possibilidades estamos usando
remédios de épocas anteriores
o objetivo então com vocês é colecionar
isso como é que foi essa mudança o que
com as suas principais aspectos
a mudança quais são as novas questões
que nós temos que enfrentar
e será que poderíamos resumir tudo em
uma solução em uma nova posição frente a
essa mudança
ainda sobre a mudança onde mudou com do
nascimento à morte
a gente não nasce mais como antigamente
a gente não é criança como antigamente a
gente não educa
nós tivemos agora há pouco uma palestra
aqui sobre isso nós não tocamos na mesma
forma a gente não namora da mesma forma
os pais ficam desesperados frente ou
ficar hoje em dia das novas gerações
achando que isso não é amor e
superficialidade
a gente não trabalha da mesma forma
qualquer um de nós aqui presente vai ter
mais uma profissão na vida a ter duas
três quatro profissões
a gente não se aposenta da mesma forma
aliás nós não nos aposentamos um pouco a
gente vai viver
aproximadamente 100 110 120 nós nossos
filhos viveram em média 120 anos o que
não vai ter possibilidade de aposentar e
nós não morremos também mais da mesma
forma
então esse mundo tá completamente a
cabeça pra baixo no nascimento por
exemplo pegar dois exemplos o nascimento
da morte no nascimento nós temos a
seleção dos embriões nós já temos
engenharia genética que pode fazer a
seleção dos embriões ea maioria das
pessoas que não estão muito à feita é
esse problema é essa essa possibilidade
vamos pensar a gente vai a gente os pais
vão selecionar os melhores embriões dos
melhores dentro dentro dos preconceitos
âmbitos da sociedade são os mais bonitos
mais altos mas enfim mais inteligentes
mais competentes não é bem assim
por exemplo nos estados unidos um casal
de de surdos selecionou tem um filho
surdo um casal já não selecionou um
filho não ea anam amanhã na dise mas
mandava ter um filho dele também
normal entre aspas aos quatro anos de
idade eu não vou conseguir mais
carregado no colo ea corte deu ganho à
essa mãe e ou estacionamento do embrião
de um milhão já não podemos do
nascimento até a morte como é que fica a
questão da morte
antigamente era uma questão natural e
hoje em dia hoje em dia nós temos vários
nomes para falar da morte
nós temos mais conhecido deles é o
tanase porquê porque a pessoa fica no
hospital anos às vezes em estado de coma
e se pergunta se a gente pode ou não
desligar as máquinas se desligar
eutanásia é proibida no brasil nós temos
outro nome que a ortotanásia
será que nós vamos ligar as máquinas ou
não vamos não ligar quer dizer fazer
ortotanásia
nós temos suicídio assistido a pessoa
tem móvel no seu próprio corpo perde um
amigo para ser a praça morto tv pessoas
conhecidas já fizeram ser sido assistido
mais conhecido e segundo fred que não
suportando mais a dor do seu câncer na
mandíbula pediu a seu médico maxwell
para ser morto
então já temos suicídio assistido nós
temos eu ea nasa nós temos ortotanásia
nós temos a recusa medicação veja
quantos nomes para algo que antigamente
era a morte chegou hoje em dia não há
morte pode ser antecipada trabalhada
postergada enfim eu acho estamos de
acordo que todos nós compartilhamos
essas novas
esses novos problemas sobre os quais a
gente está falando inclusive hoje nessa
tese que discutir essa é essa eh eh esse
turbilhão
eu tentei colocar algum dos índices
dessa mudança nesses dois aspectos em
que aterram em terra 2 e fiquei me
perguntando qual é a característica
fundamental de alteração nos últimos 30
anos e está há 30 anos sobre a mudança
do paradigma no laço social humano não
está de acordo que só os humanos
mudam a maneira de ser uma vaca
igualzinha desde o primeiro dia que foi
vaca uma bilha igualzinha deus me diga
foi abelha
às vezes nós humanos ficamos mortos de
inveja da beleza porque não te ensinar
nada pra ela sabe a distância entre ela
e uma flor
ela sabe colheu bom pólen ela sabe fazer
um mel ela sabe fazer a por 16
ela sabe fazer é densa que ela nasce nós
não nos vai fazer nada disso vantagem
portanto o cabelo
no entanto uma abelha faz a mesma
colméia desde que existe o primeiro
beijo desvantagem para ela não existe
uma abelha maia já pessoa 11 uma colméia
influenciado pelas curvas de maia em vez
de zaga no tradicional de um favo de mel
então não sei se é um hexágono mas enfim
a forma é uma forma geométrica é
bastante na estante retilínea enfim
abelhas abc abelha nós não sabemos ser
humanos vantagem para a abelha na
certeza que ela pode ser desvantagem
para nós
por outro lado ela não é criativo e nós
somos imensa vantagem para nós e época
da pós modernidade é uma época que
oferece imensa as vantagens do agente se
deparar com a nossa criatividade
dado que o índice principal era aí que
eu tava o índice principal mudou
quero isso de verticalidade de um lar
social vertical
olá social horizontal que quer dizer
isso quer dizer que nós nos organizamos
em relação a algo superior a nós
transcendência nós e isso dizia como é
que a gente deveria ser e aquilo que a
gente não deveria ser então nós podemos
ser pessoas adequadas ou pessoas
rebeldes
no mundo atual onde você não tem mais
essa orientação vertical representado na
família pelo pai que está nesses lazio
né orientação paterna
você não tem e você não tem o chefe mais
na empresa e você não tem nem mesmo a
relação uma pátria da mesma forma com
diana
nós tivemos dados mercados comuns nós
quebramos as fronteiras das identidades
dos países então frente essa mudança de
um mundo vertical para o mundo
horizontal nós nós precisamos ter um
novo tipo de burla e abuso não é mais
estável
nós não temos mais um piloto automático
nós somos todos os gps os ambulantes e
dependendo do nosso contexto a gente vai
fazendo a rota incluindo protege
encontrei um amigo ou tomar um café e
fazendo a rota não posso demorar muito
porque vai começar o ted refazendo a
rota e assim vai o nosso dia é feito de
encontros de modificações e escolhas
quero ficar aqui quero falar quero ficar
aqui quero falar não há como evitar isso
algumas pessoas se desesperam e pedem um
cardápio que seja validado um cardápio
exterior o que faz com que nós possamos
hoje em dia ser criativos ou genéricos e
genéricos o pessoal estava os que seguem
cardápios cinco livros de auto ajuda
se fosse de autoajuda que deveria
escrever então não genéricos que seus
que seguem cardápios ou criativos e
responsáveis os que sabem que cada
momento nós temos que tomar decisões
singulares
então nós tínhamos um lado terrão nós
temos uma ordem vertical nas ruas
orientação paterna
nós temos verdades estabelecidas nós
tínhamos o diálogo a sociedade anterior
a base não era o raciocínio no sentido
de um raciocínio melhor que o outro
nós tínhamos um amor intermediado uma
razão ascética e o futuro era uma a uma
projeção do presente nossos pais nos
diziam você tem que ser médico advogado
engenheiro por exemplo né
você tem que ser doutor eles projetavam
o nosso futuro
isso é uma verticalidade é um exemplo de
vez candidato na social
nada disso sustenta nada disso sustenta
na pós modernidade em terra 2
enterradores você tem ordens frontal
mundo líquido do mundo plano mundo
múltiplo você não tem mais estandes e
por não ter mais distante como dizia
você tem que a cada momento refazer
só rota através dos seus encontros das
suas articulações coletivas não existe
mais uma verdade única mas existem
certezas temporárias que é uma verdade
que não tem uma prova final são sempre
certeza temporários e que o sobre as
quais nós podemos sofrer modificações
com muita freqüência algum novo entre
nós nos damos muito valor que não
dávamos tanto nos autor o diálogo é um
monólogo articulado é 118º lado me foi
dado quando comecei a estudar música
eletrônica
eu venho de uma época de bossa nova não
é exatamente a música eletrônica
o dos clássicos dos estados americanos
os dois gostam nove estados americanos
têm em comum que você canta junto a muda
a música que está sendo cantava junto
com intérpretes da música eletrônica
é uma música difícil definir o número de
batidas por minuto e aonde você não
canta junto é porque não tem letra só
tem ritmo e isso por uma pessoa da minha
geração é uma coisa estranhíssima foi
muito chamaram essa música de bate
estaca
no entanto quando a gente nem tanto me
chamou a atenção ao ir por exemplo uma
tecla no ranking de ver dois milhões de
pessoas no meio de uma avenida dançando
essa música chamada de bate estaca
foi engraçado o bate-estaca junta mais
gente do que bossa nova junta mais gente
que jesus junto há mais gente que os
estados americanos ele esse pessoal tá
junto sem se falar
então ou abriram a porta do edifício que
tem um bando de gente que está lá sem se
falar
hoje estão descobrindo alguma outra
coisa que é que a gente pode estar
juntos em compartilhar o mesmo
significado das coisas está ligado à
onde expressão está ligado que muitos
pais acham que é uma bobagem o que é uma
linguagem fácil com uma linguagem só de
testagem de canal não é bobo e disse
isso me faz sentido e talvez isso faça
sentido para você mas não
necessariamente o mesmo
isso explica porque os virais atinge
milhões de pessoas porque se tivesse um
sentido um significado fechado
atingiriam grupos pequenos
pessoas e esses meninos podem conviver o
estar junto sem a necessidade sem a
necessidade da compreensão
isso é estranho não o amor é assim não é
só se alguém acha que você entende
porque ama vai fazer uma dr
uma discussão de relacionamento nunca
uma guerra dá certo só dá certo quando
você termina o relacionamento você
sempre sabe por que você não ama alguém
são têm menor daí por que você ama
alguém tanto que você disse alguém eu te
amo te ama mesmo nenhum outro acham que
você sabe muito bem porque você ama não
é
então eu eu eu acho importante que esses
meninos já estão mostrando novas
soluções para a terra 2 proposta
modernidade
aonde nós temos uma era do ressoar o
ressoar que distinto raciocinar o
ressoar tem um outro tipo de pegada e
faz com que cada pessoa tem que completa
completar por si mesmo aquilo que está
ouvindo como vocês esperam também
fazendo neste momento em cima daquilo
que eu tô falando cada um de vocês tá
bom da experiência pessoal está
complementando e o que quer dizer que a
gente vive no terreno mal entendido e
uma entendido não é ruim
ele é criativo e ele leva a
singularidade de cada um e se nesse
mundo do ressoar nós temos um novo amor
escreve aí novo amor o diferencial do
amor anterior amorim anterior do mundo
erra um era um amor era um amor de
intermediado eu estava com alguém por
causa do filho da herança da igreja do
pai da mãe da morte
enfim era estou com você por causa de
qualquer coisa
hoje em dia eu só estou com alguém mesmo
que eu diga por que é que ocorra por
alguma razão terceira eu estou com
alguém porque eu quero estar com alguém
porque se eu não quisesse eu não estaria
nós não temos desculpa mais frente às
nossas escolhas
nós estamos no mundo da razão sensível
brasileiro alguém responde muito bem
razão sensível e o futuro não é mais uma
projeção do presente invenção do
presente qualquer moço sabe que nós
estamos hoje
inventando o futuro e não e não a gente
não é que a gente esteja projetando
porque a gente constrói a cada momento a
gente um pra começar aí pra pouso foi
pra resumir tudo isso em um em um
aspecto
hoje em dia a gente pode mais do que a
gente quer e quando a gente pode mais o
que a gente quer
a cada momento a gente vai ter que dizer
o que a gente quer porque nem tudo que
nos é ofertado
nós queremos muitas vezes a gente quer
viver mais dez anos
mas será que a gente quer viver mais dez
anos dependendo das condições
tecnicamente eu posso viver mais dez
anos
mas será que quero enfim é um mundo que
chama a responsabilidade do sujeito
humano a cada instante
esse mundo é derivado de uma revolução
tecnológica do efeito da tecnociência
sobre nós e níveis ea sigla americana
para falar da nanotecnologia da
biotecnologia da informática e da cognis
tividade ainda não é uma sigla
mundialmente aceita mas a meu ver será
por isso que estou falando dela você ou
você opera um câncer por exemplo o fato
de poder agir no no espaço um
bilionésimo do metro você
a operação é biotecnológico você
consegue lidar com essas informações
e você tem uma inteligência para
postergar esse esse câncer frente às
tecnologias existem três posições isso
também já foi abordado nas três posições
básicas são eu não quero que a
tecnologia avance sons bilhão defensores
os meios conservadores
eu acho que as máquinas ondas pra passar
são os poços humanistas o ou não eu acho
que existe uma complementariedade entre
a inteligência artificial e o ser humano
que são os transumanistas um grande
debate em tornar isso que a gente fica
para uma próxima discussão
terminando nós temos um campo de
girassóis nós temos os girassóis de van
gogh
eu queria falar um minuto sobre a
artista dizendo que aécio aqui o a pós
modernidade nos pede a ética que pode
condenar nos pede é a ética do artista
que é ética do artista ele inventa uma
coisa que não existia nesse campo não
existia esse girassol que van gogh viu
mas a partir do momento que van gogh viu
ele também nos faz ver um campo de
girassóis de maneiras diferentes
quem gosta de van gogh olha qualquer
girassol e disse parece um van gogh um
artista consegue fazer duas coisas
ele sabe que o mundo é incompleto que
não tem porque não tem nenhum caminho
automático que eu tenho que inventar uma
solução ponto 1 e tenho que expor essa
solução e responsabilizar por ela
ponto 2 o que faz o artista não acho que
nós estejamos nós tenhamos aqui um
talento de van gogh pode até ser mas
todos nós temos que ter a ética de um
van gogh do chico buarque de 11 de maio
de um jorge amado pessoas que inventam
um mundo e se responsabilizam por ele
fazem com que a gente veja uma banda de
chico vai à bahia lembra jorge amado e
assim por diante
aqui é uma forma da responsabilidade
singular frente a pós-modernidade
sendo assim eu acho interessante que
para ir para a terra 2
é importante que nós temos dois aspectos
e de invenção que uma solução singular e
r de responsabilidade frente a essa
invenção
muito obrigado
[Música]